cats pretty much own the internet now
picture a cat photo going viral on
Twitter it is so cute that more and more
of your friends friends of friends are
sharing it and in no time it's becoming
a thing everybody's talking about on the
internet but how does this tweet make
its way from one person to another to
millions and then hundreds of millions
of people how does Twitter make it
happen imagine all of that data and
numbers processing at a really fast
speed hi I'm Priyanka vergarya and this
is architecting with Google Cloud I am
so excited to take you on this journey
to explore how Twitter does it all
[Music]
every day over 200 million people come
to Twitter to find out what's happening
in the world and to talk about it you
know important stuff like the cat
pictures as you can imagine there is a
large amount of data generated when
using Twitter in tweeting retweeting
viewing or liking a tweet all this data
makes it to the Twitter Data Center and
in Google Cloud
this data is then used by various teams
within Twitter to process analyze and
influence product decisions so we all
can use the service and enjoy its new
and improved features every day now
Twitter's data platforms are used to
improve the service through analytics
understanding and machine learning
improvements
to dig deeper let's talk Tech how does
Twitter's data processing platform work
so the first part of this process is
that we built a sophisticated log
pipeline system using industry standard
applications like Apache hadoot Kafka
and flu along with some other
aggregation Services we built in-house
these services will collect all of this
information
aggregate it and push it out to our
internal employees for consumption
Twitter employees run millions of
queries a month on almost an exabyte of
data stored across tens of thousands of
bigquery tables in Google cloud and
Twitter's internal data processing jobs
process over an exabyte of uncompressed
data
so the question becomes how does the
exabyte of data make its way into Google
Cloud
[Music]
yeah thanks to the advanced data
analytics capabilities overclock
bigquery
Twitter decided to move a majority of
our analytics use cases into Google
Cloud
and power them with bigquery so these
are powered by the event logs data among
other data sources
so as you may imagine Priyanka we had to
build replication services that copy the
data from Hadoop distributed file
systems we call it hdfs and Kafka in our
data centers into Google Cloud
replicating petabyte scale data from one
environment to another is not an easy
task it comes with challenges such as
keeping the constantly moving data in
sync between the source and the
destination some serious network
connectivity challenges and scrubbing
that sensitive data for security
I am definitely curious how Twitter
managed to solve these challenges in
replicating data from on-premises to
Google Cloud so Twitter replicates this
data in two different ways one is
battery replication and another
streaming application
so we have a collection of tools and
services to replicate this data in batch
from hdfs changing from Individual jobs
to a platform scale self-service
solution and these jobs and tools the
interest data from hdfs to Google cloud
storage and then Google Cloud Storage to
bigquery
let's discuss about streaming
replication service so on the streaming
replication side we have a service
called sparrow that uses Kafka Google
puff server and bigquery streaming to
layer data to bigquery
once the data is in bigquery the
employees across different teams use
this data to power lots of different use
cases great so once this data has made
it into bigquery how do teams actually
use this data can you give me some
examples of use cases for bigquery at
Twitter
foreign
[Music]
yeah so once the use case that we all
experience when we land on Twitter
homepage is our timeline
the timeline scheme creates machine
learning models and performs analytics
on massive timeline data stored in
bigquery
this is to ensure that we see the best
possible tweets on our timelines the
other one closer to my heart is abuse
detection bigquery ml provides anomaly
detection capabilities identifying data
and observations that deviate from the
common behavior and patterns of our data
but there are lots of other ways to do
this let's see how the Twitter team
handled abuse detection using bigquery
great question Priyanka so using
bigquery and specifically bqml and SQL
queries on top of our data in bigquery
we can analyze interaction data like
replies content of tweets and more from
all that data to investigate abusive
behavior on the platform
and then using bqml with our own models
we're able to actually analyze those
models and validate that they work for
abuse detection
using bigquery has significantly
increased the velocity of investigating
these types of issues we're talking
about petabytes of data generated per
day and that needs an easy to manage
scalable storage and analytics system so
how did Twitter manage the storage part
of this puzzle
yeah this one took us a while to get
right we ended up creating two different
kinds of gcp projects compute projects
and storage projects and we explicitly
ensure that all of our compute related
things like data flow jobs or SQL
queries run with bigquery for example
are run only in compute projects and
separately we store all of our data for
bigquery and storage projects bigquery
can process large amounts of data in few
seconds because it is very different
from the traditional node-based cloud
data warehouse Solutions it offers
immense scale flexibility performance
and cost control by decoupling storage
and compute so what are the main reasons
for separating compute and storage in
Twitter projects
running complete jobs in compute
projects allows each user for example an
employee team or an organization to have
their own workspace
this facilitates avoiding noise enabled
problems for bigquery slot consumption
as well as codas
then storing data in a separate storage
project enables us to add strict data
compliance standards with respect to
data privacy security and ultimately
protection
if a large number of teams
Gail and official efficiency
getting them access to the data easily
is a top priority and that comes down to
organizing the data the right way let's
find out how Twitter handles
organization of data
[Music]
great question so while designing the
bigquery storage structure we made sure
to keep ease of use as a core Focus we
wanted to make sure that our engineering
teams our data scientists and everybody
were able to create bigquery storage
projects and data sets via self-service
and configure them anytime
and Beyond the event log data that we
talked about earlier we also needed to
support data that's owned by service
accounts or by employees now tell me
more about this identity and access
management that's needed to support the
self-service access to data yeah so to
support the variety of different types
of owning entities like I just talked
about for example those service accounts
and individuals we ended up breaking up
our storage projects into different
kinds we ended up going with one storage
project type per owning entity type so
for example we can have a storage
project that's owned by the tweets
service account
and in this case a service account is an
identity associated with a given service
so for example the Tweet Services
account would be used for services that
involve tweets and teams will typically
use a service account for production use
cases
additionally we can also have a storage
project for
each individual person for example me as
a Twitter engineer and it would contain
the data that I produce in my day-to-day
work and in ad hoc or a development
setting you mentioned event logs what
are they and how do you store them so
the coming back to that event log data
that we mentioned earlier those are
going to be the things that we collect
from twitter.com properties that's going
to be things like interactions or faves
or those types of things and we have
those streaming into our data centers as
we talked about before
but due to the large number of different
types of log categories that we have we
decided to consolidate some of those
where it makes sense so instead of
having a single log category stored in a
storage project we group them when it
makes sense this helps teams find
related log categories in the same
projects and keeps unrelated log
categories in separate projects and then
to further simplify discovery of these
log categories we have a view project
that contains one view for each of the
backing log category tables that keeps
the act the experience of accessing them
consistent with our on-premise Solutions
there is a lot happening here and just
so all the configurations are taken care
of and the data user can just use the
data to do the analysis or use it in
their projects right away I'm curious
about the provisioning process for the
data storage structure in bigquery
foreign
storage projecting processes automated
so our internal customers did not have
to remember all bits and pieces of the
configuration
therefore we built an automation service
on gke that uses infrastructure as code
we are terraform configurations
then we also have Source control yaml
configuration files that act as source
of Truth where employees add their IDs
for their service accounts log names as
well as their user identity tell me more
about the automation service what does
it do what happens when the service runs
yeah so when the service is triggered by
a cloud schedule what it does is it
generates a terraform configurations for
new projects as well as it reconciles
the existing projects and resources to
maintain compliance with our bigquery RT
the generated terraform configuration
includes a number of resources and
policies like the name of the default
data set whether it is a user or logs
appropriate Access Control mechanisms
like reader and writer group permissions
to view and write data to this data set
and enable essential apis like bigquery
and bigquery data transfer service
you know Priyanka the privacy and
security of data stored in bigquery is
absolutely essential
therefore the automations are also
secures a project by attaching it to an
appropriate VPC service controls
parameter and it then enables
organization policies like Dometic
status sharing we cannot really talk
about data without talking about
security and governance how
Ure and monitor data
So within Twitter we built a system that
monitors all the different data across
all of our different storage platforms
that includes things in bigquery like
data sets and tables along with bigquery
models and other types of things these
Services identify the different types of
data stored classifies those pieces of
data into different classes and
registers that information in Twitter's
internal metadata systems this includes
things like bigquery data sets and
tables annotations on those tables
annotations on those models
classifications for them and then
setting appropriate retentions for those
as well now however you slice it setting
up a data Plum is a challenge at any
scale but especially at Twitter scale
modularity is the key here separating
the storage from compute which meant
creating thousands of Google Cloud
projects and data sets I'm sure you ran
into challenges that you had to overcome
can you go over some of those challenges
foreign
piece of this puzzle we work closely
with multiple Google Cloud engineering
teams to increase the limits Beyond
normally available thresholds on the
platform
let's take an example we have to
increase the VPC service controls access
policies default limit to accommodate
several thousands of projects as you
just correctly mentioned
moreover to scale our hybrid Cloud
infrastructure for data processing using
bigquery we work with Google class
significantly increasing the limits on
the number of projects a host VPC shared
VPC project can have
although we mentioned only two of the
most important scalability changes we
also face challenges in other areas like
the number of bigquery data sets in a
table the number and size of data
load jobs per day in a project as well
as Services slot management at this
scale which is a hard problem to solve
the key to building a successful data
platform is to keep the customer
experience at the core of your tooling
and Twitter implementation proves that
they build a scalable generic components
enabling flexibility in Frameworks now
and then easier growth in future exactly
using these principles we were able to
build a scalable and easy to use system
for bigquery at Twitter
and I must mention that bigquery at
Twitter has seen absolutely explosive
adoption rate and it shows no sign of
slowing down no sign is slowing down at
all and big thanks to the Google
bigquery team at Google PSO who works so
closely with us to make sure that our
framework at Twitter with bigquery is
able to reliably and securely run at our
scale
and how Twitter designed their next
Generation data platform using Google
Cloud so we can enjoy those cat pictures
if you like this video go ahead and hit
that like button share more of your
feedback in the comments below
foreign